so if people have questions would you
please come up so we have seven minutes
and and kindly identify yourself and ask
a brief question and if you want to
point it to a particular a presenter
that'll be a help okay okay and I will
try to alternate and and Aaron and
Joseph if you want to come up and be
easier okay we have a couple of mics
here so okay all right go ahead please
he was sorry so they were standing
before all right please good all right
my name is yet I'm a mathematician I
just have question a little bit more
technical so about a complete and
elimination of nuclear warheads so what
about the positive possibility of using
it on like deflecting asteroids hitting
Earth what about that that's max
question if Maurice yeah we were heads
we usually will be hit by an asteroid at
some point that question isn't if but
when if the good news is that it's
pretty easy to deal with you just need
to and what you really need to do is
just fund an early warning system cheeps
setup of telescopes around the world
connected to the Internet it gives 50
years advanced warning or so the bad
news is we haven't been bothered doing
that costs it would cost about the same
as the movie revenues from all Hollywood
asteroid movies so far once you have the
advanced warning they can figure out
exactly when it's going to strike how
earth will be rotated at that time and
where it's gonna strike if you find this
going to land in houston then you do
your fundraising in Bruceton for the
deflection mission and it's going to go
really well so that's why i only have to
fund the search but you don't want a new
kit it's then instead of having one
thing coming after you have 10,000
things coming at you all you need to do
if you have a lot of advanced warning is
this nudge it a little bit and they're
much less violence techniques the quick
follow-up question that is going to be
the same warhead we use to nuke actually
like silos and now we don't use nuclear
weapons at all you
the rocket you landed on there and
actually because if you think about the
relationship between momentum and energy
it's actually better to just take little
pieces of stuff and throw to push it
away kind of slowly on a conveyor belt
that gives much more momentum for the
energy spent so the new kingdom is just
done for Hollywood effects thank you
alright next one please I think you are
all four for your talks um I can imagine
that someone new to the issue of nuclear
disarmament might perceive a certain
tension in the messaging of the various
talks which is that on the one hand a
nuclear weapons seem to have been very
unusual in protecting ourselves from
attacks and on the other end there is
this historical evidence that when it
comes to our foreign policy and kind of
the elite national interest there does
seem to have a certain have been a
certain political component so I think
in the you know and I think there isn't
necessarily a contradiction in that in
that there you know on the one hand you
have the you know the actual people at
stake when it comes to our domestic
interest and you know when it comes to
foreign policy is really only a couple
of you know people that would benefit
from this but I think in terms of how we
as a movement message these various you
know arguments against nuclear weapons
how can we do that in a way that doesn't
confuse people as to what our argument
isn't and maybe Joseph you can go first
but i'm not sure if other people want to
join yeah so so i think what you see
from that list that i have in from from
from greater detail is that clearly in
all of the cases where there's been
these first strike preparations and
threats it hasn't necessarily led to the
results that the US presidents wanted
but in a number of cases they have and
so my sense is that is we move forward
we have to be on absolutely solid
intellectual ground and to say that it
never works I think puts us in a week in
position as we're in in public and
policy arguments with those who will
know the other side of history whether
the cases where it has worked and we
take for example in night they were
perceived to have worked take for
example 1991 that threat basically that
threat was as the United States was
assembling its forces in Kuwait the
500,000 troops for the invasion the base
the warning
to Saddam Hussein don't attack us while
we're vulnerable here because we're not
set up yet or will will eliminate you so
I mean we're going to have to deal with
those those arguments but deeper level
is why the hell we were there in the
first place I think just to add
something this I think it's wonderful
that we are all these fine nuances and
differences between ourselves when we're
talking here that when we talk to the
much broader community we should simply
build a strong as possible alliance by
keeping it very simple and it's there's
no and and there are if you have a very
strong argument the best thing to do is
to understate it a little bit so you're
less vulnerable to being criticized I
think we can all agree okay even if you
want to create nuclear deterrence you
don't need 7,000 you don't need 2,000
either so step one let's reduce your
nuclear arsenals a little bit let's not
spend the trillion dollars upgrading
them we let in just one sentence you
know let's not spend more money making
yourselves less safe that's what I would
suggest we all say with one voice to
people haven't thought about this very
much I just add one one thing is that i
think that the struggle in terms of
getting down nuclear weapons to a very
low number or eventually eliminating
them this struggle must be a part of the
ninety-nine percent versus the one
percent i think when we are able to make
the connections against the
environmental damage against all the
money that's being spent on things that
routinely spending on i think people
will resonate like the subway man in the
talk about nuclear submarines or mbta so
sorry for ten seconds add a personal
excited to have two more people okay
just quick yeah so I think it's just an
important perspective of you know um you
know what what elaine was saying earlier
the component of race and who's targeted
at you know it's important like like
Joseph said to you know be new on
tonight but I agree with all of you
about yeah or you said thanks thank you
there's a popeyes afternoon
if you call this afternoon for those of
you who wanted more of an introduction
mm-hmm that's right Alan are you okay
please yeah so my question is concerning
the basically you're the MIT student no
no I'm a student do you write so
recently there is a cheating scandal at
Malmstrom and those a drug scandal there
as well and among the officer corps
where people because you need a hundred
percent of you know we're like
ninety-eight percent a percentage on the
test that you used to qualify and that
they these officers have to keep
retaking these they just cheated they
just texted one other the answers and so
my question is really what's assuming
that you know we have we remain on
hair-trigger alert how do we move
forward with the human aspect of this do
we you know write a program that
basically says well for ninety-nine
percent confident that it's a nuclear
strike will send it right to the
president to keep the people the
officers in charge despite the sort of
less graham glamorous lifestyle they
have and the cheating that might go
along with it Lizabeth an errand whoever
wants to go on that elizabeth hasn't had
a chance um so you're asking whether we
should get those people out of the loop
no they're not in the loop in terms of
assessing an incoming attack they're
there at the other end where they would
turn the keys that would launch the but
in terms of morale so it's me as we move
towards you know what do we do about
those people do we let them because keep
the keys I mean are we gonna let people
who are having drug scandals and
basically cheating on their exams to be
qualified for this do we get them out do
we just replace them or do we have a
change in the status quo well I think
for starters you take those missiles off
alert so it's not a problem okay
okay good thank you for your question
unfortunately we are out of time